let's go next to our caller from the 757
area code who's calling today from 757
hey David
did you say this is James Jay yeah
what's going on Jay yeah what's up man
hey so I'm Ernie supporter you know I'm
really hopeful for 2020 I open like
Biden didn't screw it up but I also like
you know Andrew Yang and Tulsi Gabbard
like I really love their policies what
you saying about like they'll come down
to the wire they don't have a chance
winning the nomination do you think
Barney should put like Tulsi as
vice-president maybe Andrew yang is like
Secretary of Treasury or something like
that
I mean secretary you got to win the
nomination before we start thinking
about secretary of the Treasury I even
think it's a little early to start
thinking about VP but I listen Bernie
Warren I like in a lot of ways although
I think strategically it may not be the
best thing but I'm trying not to think
about I I mean we're just getting ahead
of ourselves but the idea of Bernie
supplemented by Elizabeth Warren's
slightly more moderate origins and very
pro entrepreneurship as we've pointed
out this week on the show I think that
that would be very very interesting but
I think it's just too early to really
make that call we got to see who wins
the primary first yeah yeah I've just
walked in like you know the court yes or
no know how that goes you know we hope
they learn from like 2016 but can't hold
your breath yeah no I know what you mean
for sure but yeah well I mean we'll have
plenty of time to sort that out I assure
you
yeah all right thanks okay great
appreciate the phone call thank you